well now to a fascinating and
significant story the media have all but
ignored
south africa is a diverse country but
the south african government would like
to make it much
less diverse an embattled minority of
farmers mostly afrikaans speaking
is being targeted in a wave of barbaric
and horrifying murders
but instead of protecting them the
government just passed a law
allowing it to seize their farms without
any compensation
based purely on their ethnicity and
distribute those farms to more favored
groups
thousands have already migrated out of
the country but they've struggled to
attack
attract any sympathy abroad for some
reason
ernst roots is deputy ceo of afra forum
it's a south africa civil rights group
he was just in the united states to meet
with a number of government officials
he also took a moment to talk to us
here's part of what he said
arch roost joins us now mr thanks for
coming on thank you very much
so what you described in this book
a disorganized but in some sense
intentional campaign
to crush a racial minority within your
country and the government
seems on board with it is that an
overstatement
well what what the book is about is it's
about government complicity in the
scourge of farm attacks and far murders
that we've seen in south africa
so we know in the last two decades
there's been according to government
statistics which we believe
we have reason to say that it's maybe
downplayed a little uh
there are about two there's been about
two farm attacks every day
and two farm murders every week uh in
south africa
and uh in the book i highlight actually
ten different reasons uh why we believe
the south african government is
complicit
and it stretches from reasons including
the fact that as these attacks have
worsened for example in 2007
there was a 25 increase in these attacks
and then the south african government
responded saying we're not going to
release any more statistics about this
then also which is very concerning is
the the
uh the hate speech in south africa so we
have that's the title of the book as
well kill the buddha
which is a very popular song which is
still being sung in south africa it was
sung just the other day
so it's sung at political rallies and of
course referring to a particular
cultural
group in south africa right we have
songs like shu tabu which is a different
song
so there are variety of ways in which we
but i thought that hate speech
was now a crime punishable by prison
time in south africa or any of the
people who say this
arrested well there's a a bill on the
table to have hate speech declared a
crime
uh punishable but by prison time but
if you look at the motivation around
this it's clear
very clear that i think those in
government who are pushing this
don't regard this as hate speech as a
matter of fact they've been arguing that
it's not hate speech in court so they
would argue that they have a right to
sing about
killing killing farmers and then they
would say it's an expression of freedom
of speech
so now the government has announced
that it plans to pursue a policy of
taking land away from people on the
basis of their skin color do you think
they'll do that
well that's what that's what was adopted
in in our parliament in february a
motion was adopted that the
property rights clause in the south
african constitution has to be changed
to allow for expropriation of private
property without compensation
so the state president sir ramaphosa
said that this would turn south africa
into the ultimate paradise and the
garden of eden
and deputy president david mabusa even
went further saying that
basically threatening white farmers that
if they do not
voluntarily hand over their land to
black people then there would be a
violent takeover
so the situation is very dire in south
africa but the good news is that that
there's still a process that has to be
followed and that's why we are in the
united states there's a sense that the
people being murdered
deserve it because of what their
ancestors did
and the international community is
similarly silent
have you met with any government
officials here in washington about
what's happening in your country well
that's why we are here
we are about to meet with some
government officials and it's very
unfortunate the situation
uh that you've just mentioned so there's
especially in south africa there's a
hierarchy of recognition
so some people when there are the
victims it's all over the news and you
hear about it frequently and other
people
as especially i think especially farmers
in south africa white farmers in
particular
whether they would be tortured to death
and it would receive very little news
coverage and that's unfortunately the
situation abroad as well
which is why we are very grateful to be
having this so a government official in
australia said publicly maybe we ought
to allow asylum to people being
persecuted for their skin color in your
country
and he was basically laughed at yeah and
then attacked
by your government for saying that yes
he was attacked and um they then said
that he shouldn't say that because he
was
he um afriforum was providing them with
false information while the information
that we are quoting is government
statistics
um so that is the situation uh whoever
speaks out against this we
just for being in the united states
we've been accused of treason we've had
people threatening us
saying they'll wait for us at the
airport when we come back and they'll
attack us and so forth
we had the state president today in
parliament calling us calling on us to
go back to south africa
um so whenever you speak out against
this there's a very serious backlash
this is not what nelson mandela wanted
no it's the exact opposite than what he
wanted he
he publicly he spoke about a free
country in which people were not judged
by the color of their skin
and he even wanted uh pharma text to be
a priority crime he said that when he
was president and when his um
presidency was over they deprioritized
it so you just watched something like
this happen in a neighboring
country zimbabwe which went from being
one the richest in africa to the poorest
in the world
because of farm uh attacks and because
of the theft of private property
are the is the anc the ruling party in
south africa
aware of that lesson yeah well they are
but you know that saying real communism
has never been tried that's what they
keep saying so
it failed in zimbabwe it failed in cuba
it failed in venezuela it failed in
russia it failed in china in all of
those countries
and they they're basically saying that
we're going to try the same thing
but this time it's going to work so last
question it's considered basically
immoral in the united states to talk to
you or to
hear stories like this for reasons that
nobody ever bothers really to explain
but it's just understood
if you could speak to our media or the
people who are dismissing
your claims as false what would you say
we want them to call on the south
african government to say listen you are
calling on us to invest in in your
country but you want to expropriate
those investments uh number two we are
we are speaking with
the us government and asking them to put
pressure on the south african government
which
could be done in a variety of ways and
number three members of the public and
members of the media the
best thing that you can do to help us is
to talk about this to talk about it on
public platforms and
in that way to continue to put pressure
on the south african government not to
continue with this policy just to tell
the truth i agree mr
mr thank you thank you very much thank
you for being